mrs henry's class has 64 crayons
at the end of the year
only 31 crayons remain
how many crayons have been used and they
give us a picture here so the beginning
of the year this is 64 crayons six tens
and four ones one two three four five
six tens and one two three four ones so
this is 64 at the beginning of the year
and at the end of the year only 31
crayons remain well 31 is three tens and
one one
three tens one ten two tens three tenths
and one one so how many have been used
and try to pause the video and try it on
your own
all right i assume you have tried it
let's do it together so there's a couple
of ways to do it if we didn't have the
picture here we would say all right she
started her class started with 64
crayons
they used some so for using crayons that
would kind of subtract the crayons away
so if you're using some crayons you'd
subtract some number from 64. so i'm
just going to put a blank here so 64
minus the number that are used is going
to be equal to the number that remain so
this is going to be equal to what's left
over and they tell us that 31 crayons
remain
31 crayons remain so we ascend we need
to figure out what's here what is this
blank 64 minus blank is 31.
well 64 minus blank is 31 then i can
swap the 31 in the blank that means that
that means that 64 minus 31 is going to
be equal to blank
that means that 64
minus 31
minus
is going to be equal
is going to be equal to
blank how did i do that how do i think
about that well imagine 64 things so
this is if this block represents 64.
so this is 64
just like that
and if this is 31
if this is 31
and then this is our blank
this is our blank we know that the blank
so this is i could put a question mark
here if i like i could put a question
mark so this is the question mark so we
know that 64 minus the question mark
would be 31
or the 31 plus question mark would be 64
or that 64 minus 31 is going to get us
the question mark right over here
so we just have to figure out what 64
minus 31 is and let's do that
let's do that right over here so 64
minus 31
minus
and it's going to be equal to
so let's look at the ones place four
ones minus one one is going to be three
ones
six tens minus three tens is
three tens so the blank is 33 and you
could check that 64 minus 33 is 31 or 64
minus 31 is 33 so 33 crayons have been
used now since they made this neat
picture for us we actually could have
just used the picture how would we have
done that well this is what they started
with this is the 64. six tens
one two three four five six tens and one
two three four ones so 64 and they end
up with 31.
so how many of the tens do we use up to
go from what we started with to what we
finished with
well we end up using let's see there's
only three tens here there were six tens
here so we used one two three tens
so we used up
three tens
and how many ones do we use up well we
have four ones here and we only have one
right over here so we use up three ones
we used up
three ones if you take away these three
tens and these three ones you'll be left
with the same number of crayons that we
have at the end of the year so we use up
three i guess you could say we used up
three ten packs and we used up three
ones so what's that going to be well
three tens plus three ones is
is
33.